the only thing they can be sure of about
the future is it will be absolutely
fantastic welcome everybody to this
special kovat 19 edition of the arthur c
clarke center for human imaginations
into the impossible podcast i'm your
fearless host Brian Keating a professor
of physics at UC San Diego talking with
a fellow physicist astronomer writer and
barber of my book and I owe him many
things including a blurb from my book
and proofreading it a long time ago more
than three years ago now it's David
Brent dr. David Brin who is a
world-renowned writer
award-winning writer and also a
scientist and he maintains a flourishing
catalogue of all his musings on his
website which is called the contrary
Brin and I'll put a link to that in the
show notes and I wanted to talk to David
on the podcast for a very long time but
and but a particular article of his and
contrary Brin which you can find at
David Brin blog spot.com was really
focused on sort of the tagline the
subheading which is looking towards the
future and David first of all let me
welcome you and ask how are you doing
and where are you where I'm down by the
beach where are you currently well I
happen to know you are but you are
behaving the law better than if you were
at la jolla shores at this moment but
I'm in my office at home for maybe that
adjustment is not as great as for most
people most days I am working right here
by the writing fiction or nonfiction or
that sort of thing I'm still waiting to
hear from NASA's innovative and advanced
concepts program as to whether or not
there's going to be a orientation
meeting because I'm on their team of
advisers
the Advisory Council for Nayak whether
there's going to be meeting back east
and DC in June and I expect it'll be
canceled but I'm hoping we'll get past
all of this in time for Nayak's
symposium in October because it's a
highlight of my year to participate in
NASA's most innovative and most far-out
an almost science-fictional program and
giving grants to two small seed grants
to groups that think they have something
a bit outside the envelope that's worth
the best interesting I heard a seed
funding or you know phase one study was
approved for a radio telescope on the
far side of the Moon today I don't know
if that's was under your purview or not
yes when I have just announced its its
new grants and there are a number of
things
Joel Circo trans Astra for example has
grants to one to investigate mining of
asteroids for water and another tooth
has an innovative way to get solar power
down into the deep craters at the lunar
poles where the ice is and the ice is
there because the sunlight never falls
there says a hard fine copious solar
power with this refining the water from
a place where there's it exists there
because there's never a solar power
right exactly it's like the solar
powered flashlight I once received as a
swag gift from the SPIE that kind of
confused me at first oh I used to
collect the hand powered flashlights but
the solar power flashlights that's a
funny one yes so so David today we
wanted to get your get your opinion on
this obviously this whole brave new
world sort of cliche that we seem to be
and I I spoke last week with my friend
your friend Michael Shermer ma into the
impossible podcast that should be out by
the time people hear this and we
discussed kind of well that science
fiction and science fiction authors play
in really visualizing the future and
helping us and you know to some are more
successful in your case and then others
that one than the others but but what is
it about science fiction that can be
used is it is its ability to sort of run
as Einstein called Gedanken experiments
thought experiments what about science
fiction enables people to be futures
because on the face of it they're not
necessarily related right
yes well the whole question of
prediction is is a fraud and a difficult
one
professor tetlock for example has been
leading efforts that I've been engaged
in because I am one of those science
fiction authors who speaks at the CIA
and other agencies and ulay because they
really want to get one more way of
parting the curtain but as Setlock
points out even when you develop a new
way to part the curtain on the future
and model better for example all that
does is move the goalposts a little
we're all used now to these wonderful
fantastic weather models for example
where you can get a vague general idea
what the weather is going to be like in
your region ten days out and that for
the next 48 hours it's really useful
hour-by-hour yes when I was in head you
know you were lucky if the to our
weather report was even vaguely in the
right direction
this is a fantastic sign of the
competence in advancement of the models
of people who are using the same
technologies in the same formulas as the
climate people
during global climate change so it
really puts a burden of proof on people
who deny climate change that the models
that they use to plan their vacations or
what - whatever that day suddenly are no
darn good when applied to similar
problems but what happens in what
tetlock points out is that when you move
the goal posts you only make the problem
harder and especially if everybody gets
models like models with the economy or
models of the stock market then
everybody starts using them and that
makes the models no good anymore right
so what science fiction does is we have
a tendency to claim we're not in this
business to predict where the highest
form of science fiction is is novels or
movies that prevent in other words we're
not trying to predict what's going to
happen where sometimes trying to prevent
things from happening and it can add
it's best be very effective
millions of environmentalists who
recruited to be active in this world in
environmental causes buy the movie
Soylent great and a number of science
fiction's stories by John Brunner and
Kate will help and others you know
showing how if we're careless we could
lose it all nuclear war retired military
officers say that it was definitely
prevented accidents were prevented by
movies like dr. Strangelove fails safe
on the beach stuff like that but changed
the mindset wargames that changed the
mindset just enough so that some
potential failure roads were fixed and
the granddaddy of all self preventing
prophecies would be George Orwell's 1984
which for this day inspires millions
to worry about undue accumulation of
power by conspiring elites the
difference between a decent Democrat and
a decent Republican and miss used to be
the case back when both were lively
species is that the decent Democrat is
afraid that Orwellian powers are being
accumulated by would be Big Brother's of
aristocracy and wealth and faceless
corporations and a decent Republican is
afraid that big brother is coalescing
among snooty academics and faceless
government bureaucrats but if you put it
that way
that was right both are dangerous and we
should be guarding each other's backs
and the one thing that's gonna collapse
this last decade or so has been this
sense that regarding each other's backs
instead we've been pitted against each
other so you know is has mob said Isaac
Asimov said no it was Fred pull it's not
the science fiction authors job to
predict the automobile it's our job to
predict the traffic jam what are the
possible repercussions of these advances
and so you know I've I've done
predictions in the near future the
intermediate future which is really hard
in my novels earth in existence and then
there's the far future where you can
have lots of fun you have their own work
Drive and talking dolphins and and have
some great adventures but it's the
near-term stuff where you can have real
effect so we're in the middle of a
potentially existential climate of in
the biological sphere and sort of
ecological mixed with the impact of
humans and animals and that is these of
course the cove in nineteen worldwide
pandemic and what I thought would be so
timely is to
go through your thought process on how
you appraise these risk you are an
advisor as you said to certain
three-letter agencies and that's for a
reason and I think that some of the some
of the scenarios you paint that you
paint sort of long-term and perhaps
intermediate term and then certainly
longer term impacts and I think what I
want to know first of all have you ever
lived through anything comparable to
this I mean the closest that I can think
of as you September eleventh when
there's just a paradigm shift what does
this remind you of anything I mean
you're not old enough
you know I tease you and I love you but
I never say what even hint that you're
old enough to remember the depression
because of course you're not but but
from your parents from your father was a
renowned scholar himself what did he
tell you what what lessons from the past
this is comfortable in any way or we
just I'm a totally different branch of
the wavefunction right now well you know
for one thing Brian you very smartly
pointed in the right direction and the
right direction is the past science
fiction offers supposedly science is the
main thing driving our extrapolations
and our projections but that's not true
it should have been named speculative
history because a certain fraction of
science fiction mine because I have the
training is often not always based upon
next the next scientific thing but
almost all science fiction authors are
deeply steeped in history because that's
what science fiction really does it is
taking the greatest story ever told and
that is the 6,000 years of recorded
human history which is horrendous
a story of horrendous errors and in
Justices and grotesque mistakes made by
kings who who killed the people who
might have helped them to prevent that
mistake because it was
and you know how humans hate love
criticism especially human leaders the
if you look across all that time and you
see the patterns you realize that that's
the story breaking out from those
patterns from those traps and so you
know it's not for accident that my
father's a generation was called the
greatest generation they survived the
Depression when things were worse than
this they overcame Hitler when the
threat was worse than what we face he
was he was born into the 1918 flu
epidemic they all lived in deadly fear
for their children up until I was about
six years old when Jonas Salk saved
childhood by immunizing us against polio
and whereas Franklin Delano Roosevelt
was the most beloved figure for the
greatest generation absolutely adored by
them Jonas Salk was adored by the
generations of the 50s for giving us
back hope in her childhood and easing
the fears of all those people who were
far more desperately afraid for their
children
yeah when we are now for the you know
old guys like me who might be the the
top victims of the ko Fifi I mean a
coded virus so you know it's the
historical perspective I think that
we're sadly lacking and especially you
know and the political problems we have
I mean to to not recognize that across
those 6,000 years almost 99% of all
those cultures languished under
feudalism ruled by kings and and and
priests and Lords and all of that when
in the last 200 years when we escaped
from that way of life we started
actually accomplishing stuff duh
so to go back to ruled by some
aristocracy or king this is this is the
agenda that the gladden or Putin and the
Saudis had for us it's not just that
it's not our way it's a stupid way and
there's 6,000 years of proof that it's a
stupid way and so looking looking
towards the you know future without
being particularly you know the
Pollyanna I would say you
he really lists a couple of different
things that resonated especially with me
and that is is that you know in your in
your article again I'm gonna post this
in the show notes both in YouTube and
the iTunes Store for podcasts it's an
article called Reaper or more
repercussions in a play gear and some
long term the first thing I thought was
so interesting for you to sort of sight
was what may be happening behind perhaps
one of the most intriguing characters in
society today someone by the name of
Elon Musk and that's how you know sort
of these these brilliant visionaries can
perhaps take take maybe their own
initiative advisedly or not but try
thousands of seeds planted in the ground
but to see if perhaps one will bloom so
I think I want to focus on the first on
the first of your kind of major major
predictions or perhaps it's already
occurring right now and that is how we
could actually bifurcate the the problem
at its root and perhaps go and and find
some resistance or perhaps find people
via serology or other means of testing
to look for this you know people that
have recovered from this so first can
you can you talk about this idea that
may that you write could have occurred
elsewhere or could have occurred to
someone like you on musk for people that
or may not have had this illness
currently and be asymptomatic at present
well I mean it seemed obvious to me
about a month ago I started talking
about this and got really bad feedback
from people and all of a sudden now
about one week ago I start seeing the
idea everywhere and that's the job of a
science-fiction opera to get apoplectic
and and upset because nobody gives you
credit for the idea that they all called
ridiculous
just recently that's right the ridicule
phase is obvious yeah it's a standard
professional complaint in this case it's
very simple if we had good testing and
we don't yet it's been promised for some
time but if we had good testing it would
be possible for Elon Musk for example to
put out a call for Auto Workers who have
already experienced their kovat 19
infection now maybe they got sick and
recovered maybe they just simply test it
out as about a third of people do as
having had it gained an immunity and
never noticed yep you put them in
quarantine at the Pebble Beach Golf Club
which is not very far from the eelain's
Test empty rooms empty currently for one
week and keep testing them and then you
shift them over to the to the Tesla
factory and say everyone working in this
Factory is kovin positive so who are
they gonna hurt now it's true there are
listed they found about six different
sub variants of the Kovan bike team and
it is possible to get secondarily
infected with a different variant so
things are more complicated but from
what I've heard those secondary if for
healthy young or middle-aged people who
have already experienced the virus no
secondary effect in fact
infections manifest as a sniffle so the
question is how long will it be i
predict before the end of the week
before somebody comes out and says why
don't we have some restaurants that are
staffed by koban positives and are open
for kovat positives how about that
Universal Studios is for coded positives
and dizzily non first covered negatives
you can't do the latter you can't do it
for a ladder until you have really
really good rapid testing but at least
it's a path to getting things back open
again and I'll be honest with you I see
this really the only path in the near
future
now you go a little farther and you go a
little farther into the future and you
start having other things I mean the
testing opens up other possibilities but
of course like for instance doing it
intelligently doing isolation
intelligently the way to South Koreans
and the Taiwanese did and that's
actually testing everybody and then
finding the supercarriers and and doing
contact tracing now that's the standard
quarantine techniques and will be better
at that next time it's been pointed out
that the death rate for Koba 19 is
terrible but largely because it'll over
little over the sick people will over
whelmed our medical staff the death rate
is not truly horrendous by historical
standards and so some people say well
this is this is going to leave us in
much better shape first when something
really science-fictional hits something
really horrible hits and I
I have science fiction about that
there's been a lot of science fiction
about pandemics you know and well you
can go to my website I have a page of
pandemic stories and novels and movies
people are talking about how one of the
soonest treatments that they might try
out of desperation is what's called
serum now you've all heard that word and
a lot of women have skincare serums
they're called they're sold in these
little tiny bottles and it has nothing
to do with what a real serum is a real
serum is where you take blood from a
person who has survived an illness and
strain out the antibodies and give them
to a victim just to knock the virus down
so that the victim has time to develop
their own antibodies and so that's
that's being tried in a very preliminary
way around the world since you point out
in the pieces has been featured in Omega
Man and outbreak two two films that you
described is because in outbreak they
come back with the monkey that's the
original source Junior disappears into a
into a trailer a lab trailer and comes
out within 45 minutes almost instantly
saves remember so yeah it's going to get
easier because we're going to throw
resources at this man yeah and I think
you know you start off in terms of
technological changes with a call out to
the Manhattan Project and then discuss a
little bit in the context is the
greatest generation so two of my you
know kind of green shoots looking
forward is that perhaps as the Manhattan
Project did
or physics in the 20th century namely
stimulating nuclear research high-energy
particle physics of the LHC particle
physics in general both theory and these
massive colliders culminating with the
Large Hadron Collider in Europe as well
as the program to develop radar which as
you know led to the development of radio
astronomy as practical tools we'll learn
more about the universe including the
serendipitous discovery by bell
laboratory scientists Arno Penzias and
Wilson of the cosmic microwave
background radiation that I studied
those were both directly related with
with genetics and direct lineage to the
world war two so the Manhattan Project
of course much more well known for
producing the atom bomb but but equally
important and arguably more much more
important a daily basis for things like
weather radar etc was the development of
radar taking place at Lincoln labs and
and bells eventually as well so I like
to think maybe a green shoot that might
emerge is will be found in the in the
context of rapid testing which is not
you know high tech but scalability of
advanced technology but perhaps with you
know with a real Manhattan Project s
touch to develop CRISPR to develop
biological testing and editing and
capabilities for the first time
reminiscent of the Manhattan Project my
question to you is can we keep up with
nature in other words we we harness the
power of the atom you know before we
were really mature enough to use it
properly and arguably although it did
lead to the end of World War two
obviously but do you think a similar
danger could be present in this green
shoot that that we might develop
technology that might come back to haunt
us later on
whyhave as those are several very very
good questions very good points and all
my life I've heard the phrase it's too
bad that our wisdom hasn't kept up with
our technology
and my blog is called contrary britain
which means that i have an automatic
reflex that got me killed in all of my
previous lives before i was 16 years old
and i have an automatic by the way i
don't believe in reincarnation that is a
metaphor the be the reflex to be
contrarian is that in fact it appears to
me that there have been many
technologies that have not met the
schedules we expected for them like
spaceflight we expected to be at Saturn
by now mm-hmm but our ancestors even in
the greatest generation if we brought
them forward from World War two to have
seen President Obama for example to have
seen the the mixed races that are
routine on television and we take for
granted now to have seen so many things
examples of us gradually grudgingly
becoming better now it's true that right
now the forces that are preventing us
from showing the maturity towards
ecological matters that easily sixty
percent seven even seventy percent of
Americans would would prefer to see that
there are reasons why that generously
forward-looking attitude is is not it is
not propelling us as far as it should
but this is one of the reasons why I
wrote my non-fiction book called the
transparent society and that is that one
thing has enabled us to accomplish so
much in a cause
some way the positive Sun is where I win
I want to win more than you win and I
don't want to win by causing you to
loops right in a positive sum game
all I want to be is a little richer than
you I want you to be rich too a zero-sum
game is one in which I win by making you
lose and that's what happens in most
sports and that was most of human
history right if we can manage a
positive sum game then the rising tide
raises all boats and the only thing that
hasn't ever enabled that to happen is
what we innovated for the last 200 years
and that's transparency reciprocity
being able to find each other's errors
hold each other accountable and then
make alliances with each other so you
know that's a that's a whole other topic
yeah as far as as far as the
implications for this play gear is
concerned what we need to do is is take
advantage of the vast proliferation of
talent and skill that we've been
developing and the only way we can do
that is by keeping things open yeah I
look back at 9/11 you know people look
back at that the year 2001 and they
remember the Twin Towers falling but
they don't remember is something that
happened a month later and that was the
anthrax attacks this this brilliant
imbecile killed envelopes with
weaponized anthrax spores and sent them
around to sabotage and murder and a
couple people died and what was the
response of the United States government
the United States immediately said hello
all the world's experts here's what's
going on come and help and as a result
the 99.99% of skilled biological
researchers who are sane
operated to overcome the point zero zero
zero one percent who were insane yes and
the problem was solved quickly and
that's that's what we're alive for
exactly and I think you know you brought
up in that you know concomitant with the
transparent society I think has to be an
unopened miss and obviously the sunlight
being the best disinfectant and in the
book in the piece rather which turned
into a book you talk a lot about the
really you know kind of tectonic shifts
in the way that Americans have adapted
more or less instantaneously I know I'm
running you know this unlicensed daycare
center here wall advising graduate
students and trying not to you know
toilet trained a graduate student or
teach quantum mechanics to a to a
two-year-old and that's a meeting with
mixed success but but I'm getting
through it but you point out the role of
you know kind of remote virtual presence
and I wonder if you could get into that
a little bit how can society expect to
take advantage of this or do you think
as soon as the all-clear is given we
will get back to get back to our old
habits and can continue you know flying
around the world to go to you know
climate change conferences or you know
astronomical telescopes etcetera
do you see if a long-term repercussion
accruing to our benefit or do you think
you know or natural to go back to our or
wasteful old ways well I think it's
going to be sort of midway between those
two obviously for instance there's
several technologies that are going to
get a huge boost out of this beyond the
biomedical beyond the important ones
that we're going to be busting in to
handle the testing and the vaccines much
quicker than before and the detection
and all of that for one thing is going
to be local sourcing the ships that
crisscross the ocean spewing carbon into
the air and just because labor
a little bit cheaper in China that's
going to go into decline because it was
already going to go into decline because
we're gaining technologies that will
enable people in a city to get a large
fraction of their food a large fraction
of their manufacturing goods from real
close nearby ah and you know that
includes additive manufacturing 3d
printing all sorts of things and that's
going to reduce waste and so it's going
to have positive ecological benefits but
it's also going to make us more
resilient and that's a very important
word the last several times I've been
back east to talk to three-letter
agencies I've pounded the table about
resilience and there's a there's an
interview that I did with the
Proceedings of the ACM that will appear
underneath this interview and Brian will
I'm sure offer that link in which I talk
about all sorts of ways in which our
cell phones for example in a crisis is
the exact time when we need them in the
exact time they will work yes if the
cell towers will go down and we've seen
this happen many times there is a way
that our phone systems could be vastly
more more resilient and it would be very
easy and it's ready to do it is almost
turnkey we have two million solar homes
in America today almost all of them shut
down in a power blackout for a really
really stupid reason that could be
easily fixed and I speak about pandemics
and things like that this is in an
interview last year so this notion of
resilience is something that's
absolutely essential for us to the store
and one of the things will be local
sourcing and now there is yes will
develop better business meeting where
better speechifying ways of holding
meetings and things like that
and the regular meetings conventions and
all that they'll be back
this is a personal worry to me because a
substantial portion of my income has
come from public speaking and we like
paid the big bucks for a speech to a
virtual audience you might have to rely
on the proceeds
you know the honorarium that I'm sending
you after today yes that's right
another thing that you brought up and I
know that you take part in personally is
sort of this you know really ultra local
micro local economy of gardening and
subsistence can you talk about the
prospects for that in a world where you
know there could be say a second wave a
third wave would you say now is not a
bad time for people to do as you have
done with urban or maybe suburban
farming for people that can can do such
a thing I find it a great way not only
to have some resiliency measure I don't
have a huge plot but but to have have
some resiliency and also educate my kids
but what do you think about that as a as
a positive outcome of this whole awful
pendant well you know for one thing
having developed a fairly large
vegetable garden I have come to realize
that there's no way and that's green
earth I'm going to feed myself or my
family that I can swap yes I can maybe I
can borrow for a bushel a break at some
point but give you a telescope eyepiece
that I'm not using in exchange for their
you know to have the habit of
maintaining a victory garden this is one
of the positive visit the green shoots
you talk about it's almost impossible to
buy seeds right at this particular point
in April 2020 because people are are
loading up their minivans with manure
and and seeds
and going for it I think that's I think
that's terrific yeah the opposite
extreme of that impulse is of course the
preppers and they're buying up guns as
if they didn't already have 40 or 50
guns my novel the postman which was
native to that movie by Kevin Costner
and then mixed feelings about it it was
actually visualizing I know you pan it
but I actually really know I think two
out of three ain't bad it's visually and
musically one of the most beautiful
films ever shot it's my favorite Kevin
Costner movie he did not betray the
heart message about citizenship in my
work it's dumber than a stone but
gorgeous big-hearted and dumb that's
what my wife married you know and do you
see yeah you talk also about about
education which is obviously a priority
for you not only having been the product
of higher educational system and in your
your doctorate attended Cal Tech
attending UC San Diego than being a
practicing astronomer for some time
before you before you went commercial no
before you began your a lot really
illustrious career as a writer and
thinker and public intellectual which i
think is really the way I think about
you what do you see is the future of
education even before this happened I
started to think about distance learning
is my career is my job really a long
term for my students and their students
my grand students of which I have a
couple already which is kind of scary my
graduate students who are professors
themselves have now obtained their own
graduate students I think when you get
to the fourth generation you have to
quit or something but but I look at them
I look at my young graduates you know
grandchildren is it were in graduate
school what prospects will they have
when you know perhaps in not too long
from now instead of talking to me
about about astronomy they can talk to a
doppelganger of Galileo himself and why
should what relevance will I have in
such an era well you know look I'm torn
about that sort of question first off
the science fiction author in May is
happy to dive in and write stories about
such scenarios and I have I mean I am
one of my most popular stories that are
called stones of significance is set in
a pretty much post singularity world in
which we pretty much God's people are
pretty much gods because we've added to
those prefrontal lobes you mentioned new
layers little layers new layers they're
in the walls of the house and they are
interacting with us and we aren't being
dominated by AI we are a augmented
that's right and so it's great grist for
science fiction and I might mention my
short story the giving plague which is
about how viruses interact with their
hosts and find a find either a way to
kill them or come to terms with their
hosts and it's available at my website
David Brent calm you just go to short
stories and you can get this becoming
Lincoln they did Hugo nominated story
the giving plague and it's it's has
somewhat to do with the fact that even
though I was was then and am now a blood
donor and I was just prevented by the
coded saying from giving my 96th pint
but there's also another side of me and
that is the consultant that's the you
know the guy who gives you know sage
speeches about the near future and and
that guy you know says one thing and
that is it's not our job to worry about
that about whether or not are the grand
graduate students the little tiny the
distance graduate student
of your graduate students of your
graduate students talk to an AI Galileo
or whether or not they have to use sign
language because they're chimps or they
squeak through and through a translator
because they're dolphins are there
aliens are there a eyes our job is to
create a civilization that's wise enough
to raise them to be wise enough to deal
with that
that's not electro - all right have the
mm enough it's enough Daiyu it's enough
for an hour for us to raise a new
generation that's not stupid in the ways
we were just like we are not stupid in
the way our poise our parents took for
granted
my parents were liberals of their day
but they would have plotzed if I brought
home a date from from a distant race you
know if they would have got used to it
they were like that but they weren't
used to it
so it's our job to make things better
enough that our wiser and better
children can make children who are wiser
and better enough that they can what
make the makers of Star Trek very good
very good so in the last couple of
minutes before we before we break for
this inaugural episode of what I think
or and hope will be a recurring series
but we'll see depending on whether the
check actually clears that I thought
I've posted in the mail but the postman
is late today the postman exactly you've
got it so I want to just kind of close
with with some thoughts perhaps
recollections that you can share with us
of how people can develop this
resiliency of mind and I think
that's really what you're what you're
getting at with with what we don't want
graduate students well it's not just two
graduate students alone it should be sub
the public for the for the
intellectually engage public who pay our
taxes a scientist especially those of us
in state universities like myself and I
want to know you know in the end we
started off with a little bit of history
maybe we can end with a little bit of
history of how people can get engaged or
perhaps you know is there is there
something to be hopeful about that we
haven't covered perhaps you know I see
this you know globalism and and things
like that perhaps that's that's
something that we now can rely on in the
positive way maybe cooperating with
countries around the world except
instead of you know kind of fighting
with one another too because we don't
have a foe
you know that can really be vanquished
the way that we did in a war and so I
think it's hard to maintain this level
of discipline of commitment and do you
see any danger of you know society kind
of having trouble adjusting to this as a
reality or do you think that we could
pull together as generations of the past
through intellectual curiosity
engagement as we like to study here at
the arthur c clarke center do you feel
hopeful I mean what's your one in a
sentence what are you feeling right now
just at an emotional level for the
future well I'm contrary bread so if I'm
optimistic with just total you know live
assumptions of success I can shake my
finger with the best of them they're
plenty of warning signs I live in an era
in which there is too much gloom and it
is reducing our confidence which is the
basis upon which we can solve problems
and save all our lives I think the arts
have always been against us especially
against this Renaissance that escaped
from from the stupidity trap of
feudalism the odds have always been
against us and I think the odds are
still against us but with the odds only
being two to one again
just that makes me a freakin optimist in
the course of human events and I think
we can do it mom our parents generation
did it are we made of lesser stuff no I
refuse that it insults them to say that
they made a generation less good than
them and I'll tell you this my kids
generation I talked to them I took
talked to a great many of them and they
are better nicer smarter people than us
okay boomers you know and who gets the
credit for that yes that's right he's
toothpaste yeah that's right so they
can't win even even if they're better
than us ends are it off we made them
that's exactly the pattern that has to
continue and what we need to do as
boomers is stop panicking decide that we
are in favor of this Renaissance quelle
phase eight of the freakin American
Civil War and the phases go back to 1778
it wasn't just the 1860s hmm quill this
phase of the American Civil War get it
behind us and start doing what we're
good at and that is surprising everybody
very good well that certainly brightened
up my day Anna otherwise gloomy cloudy
rainy San Diego early spring day David
want to thank you for this I want to
actually schedule a revisit of this
sometime in that in the not-too-distant
future and I want to thank you for your
time
your insights as usual I want to point
out to folks that David can be found all
over the web but in particular the
article that we were quoting today can't
come from his blogspot David Brin that
blog spot.com he also maintains a
website at David
bring calm and I think you can get
interchangeably between the two I'll
provide some links and and resources in
the show notes and I want to thank folks
out there for listening and please leave
your comments in the comment section if
you're watching this on youtube please
leave a review if you're listening on
iTunes and really appreciate your time
David stay well stay healthy we need you
more than ever
well I have pretty good pretty low blood
pressure so I'm not too right but I am
scrubbing every surface so you guys take
care and and thank you Bryan Keating a
maven of maintenance and scholar of
scholars thank you David
the only thing we can be sure about the
future
[Music]
you